right and like we spoke about her
process where the first step is at
Discovery call and that's where you're
saying look yes I understand you have
roles vacancies we can talk about them
but what have you tried so far what
hasn't worked what has worked like you
need to understand you got to stop
people talking about the vacancy
actually you got to push back because
the client might want to jump into that
the other reason we push back is because
we've we've got two different teams of
people that they're going to have a
conversation with so they're going to
have a discovery call and then they're
going to have a rooll brief with the
recruitment team and we're really
conscious that it can't be telling the
same thing twice so we've got to really
separate okay Discovery is is more
strategic you know what how can we help
and then roll brief is right okay tell
me about the behaviors and
responsibilities in this job